foreign
[Music]
for quite a while
but no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
hello
we come in peace
come on Drax seriously dude
foreign
[Applause]
we have been running
our whole lives
I'm done running
[Applause]
[Applause]
we'll all fly away together
one last time
into the forever
a beautiful
girl
[Music]
and we'll kill anyone who gets in our
way no not kill anyone kill a few people
he'll know people kill one guy one
stupid guy who no one loves now you're
just making it sad
in days of Legend gods
walk the earth
[Music]
said what have I told you
Athena had returned in human form
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
I'd say your therapist is more this
paycheck
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
another Gonna Stand Down I'm not the one
to fear Prime
there is a Darkness coming
it was all a dream
[Music]
[Applause]
of all the threats
from both your past
and future
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
and if you don't know that you know girl
let's get around
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
I designed Megan to protect Katie from
feeling lonely
she will recognize you as her primary
user and when you do that you're going
to pair with her
crazy it's insane right
[Music]
Megan your goal is to protect Katie from
harm both physical and emotional
[Music]
I won't let anything harm you I love her
Megan's not a person kid you don't get
to say that
[Music]
very good
what are you doing couldn't sleep
occupational hazard
[Music]
what the hell is that
[Music]
you should probably run
I don't let anything harm you ever again
have I done something to upset you Gemma
I know you think you're maximizing your
objective function
oh really
[Music]
Megan baby doll skill don't provoke
[Music]
we'd have to shut her down Jesus Christ
[Music]
I have a new primary user now me
[Music]
did you make him do something bad
what's going on
[Music]
what are you I'm Megan
don't be Focus oh we will
hey Lizzy with my nine o'clock
sorry about the game but we're gonna
have fun tonight
let me guess another it conference I'm
gonna be back in a couple days Thomas
hey Mom Dad has a work emergency so can
you come pick me up I love it when you
call me Mom let's throw a rager
what's happening
please don't
[Music]
it is so tight it's some kind of
superhero layer your dad's a superhero
what no my dad can't handle hot wings
is out
I'd have a crazy idea
step into the spotlight please don't
kill me
now that's fast
we got him
[Music]
Whoever has this technology can do
anything
we gotta save my dad's detect before
they destroy the world
we got this
what are you gonna do tickle torture me
dude that was too long
too long
whoa whoa don't shoot I'm the IT guy I
was alerted to a security breach
why couldn't you tell me about your
secret identity how am I supposed to say
oh by the way some alien power source
chose me to be the guardian of the
planet
it makes you sound crazy right yes
lifetime's over kids let's prepare for
war
[Music]
yeah so hot you got the winter suit
[Music]
why do you come to us
my family's safe
foreign
[Music]
if you want to live here
you have to ride
let's do it
Just Breathe
breathe
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's get it done
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Avatar the way of water experience it in
3D
only in theaters December 16th
[Music]
gets on sale now
increment and initialize
I believe this task within the allotted
time if the task is not completed with
an acceptable parameters your daughter
will die
task complete
fill the pocket
[Music]
how many more of the tests are there
[Music]
Eileen
Eileen save Roger my husband
[Music]
what did you do to me
why are you doing this
oh there's my daughter
calm down
I'm very
calm
[Music]
only the most broken people
foreign
ers
[Music]
they called him
the feather serpent God
killing him
will risk Eternal War
[Music]
M
we know what you whispered
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
my son sacrificed his life to save me
these powers
are not a gift
but a curse
born out of Rage
[Music]
I don't know
this Loose Cannon needs to be locked
down before innocent people start
getting hurt
it's been asleep for 5 000 years
you find us a cell that can hold them
we'll take care of the grass who's on
the team
I didn't bring a passport you don't need
passports
we're the Justice Society
we're here to negotiate your peaceful
surrender
I'm not peaceful
nor do I Surrender
here we go
I kneel before no one
you didn't come here to see Justice
you came to exact Revenge
[Music]
chance
I never said I was a hero
you believe you are not worthy
but fate does not make mistakes
[Music]
you have two parts
you can be the destroyer of this world
[Music]
or you can be its savior
[Music]
okay that is new glad you guys are still
finding ways to spice things up we're
leaving in five okay
these are the amazing people I'm gonna
be spreading the break with group shot
I kind of wanted to save this prize but
whatever I'll tell you guys now it's a
smart house so I'll send you guys a link
okay let's do this
now you guys are excited told you I'd
come through wow Andrew Collins you go
by Drew right welcome home
I've been designed and programmed to
cater to your every need so she's like
the house or what most people just call
me Marco
kidding me now go explore
[Music]
I have quite the weekend in store for
you
this entire place is one gigantic 3D
printer
don't tell me you can't handle this
you hear that
something I've been working on for a
long time
I've never seen ai's this Advanced what
the hell did you do to them I can't wait
to show you what outside
who wants to party
[Music]
foreign
what happened to you
I don't remember
before I knew you I didn't really know
what I wanted in life
and then I mentioned I feel like I'm
going somewhere
and I don't even know where but I just
know I want to go there with you
ready to tell us what happened to you
were you alone
I said I don't remember
what I'm trying to say is
you're my person Ruth
what is wrong with you
I love you but people change
Someday I'm Gonna Change
maybe you love that new version
and maybe
okay it's just I haven't been feeling
like myself
[Music]
[Music]
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at ex-con
how are you an Avenger that doesn't make
sense
but everywhere I go people tell me the
same thing thank you Spiderman
people still need help that that's why
we made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum Realm
turn it off
now
[Music]
where
armies
[Music]
beneath ours
what are you so afraid of
there's something I never told you
[Music]
laughs
it isn't what you think
[Music]
[Music]
I can get you home
and give you more time
you've helped me
so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man
[Music]
I'm an idiot
it's your time I don't deserve these
Powers if I'm being honest like what am
I even contributing
wow there's already a superhero with a
red suit with a lightning bolt on it
Aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and Batman is so cool and I'm just
me
foreign
[Applause]
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and I'm the only one trying to
keep it together
[Music]
you understand I'm a pediatrician
right
come on
coming for you
[Music]
children stored the power of all the
gods
very personal belief
[Music]
look I might not have as much experience
as you because I'm not super old like
you but I've seen all of the Fast and
Furious movies Lady it's all about
family guys that was a signal
[Music]
the world will not survive this
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I think I know how to fix this dude but
I really don't
everyone can be worthy let's give it a
chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
I just threw a truck and a dragon I love
my life
[Music]
[Music]
Mrs Wang are you with us I am paying
attention
now you may only see a pile of receipts
story
I can see where this story is going
does not
what's happening
[Music]
I get a husband I'm gonna have food from
Another Universe I'm here because we
need your help
very busy today I'm so tired to help you
across the Multiverse
I've seen thousands of evidence
their emotions
even this kill Ed
the great evil despite the many verses
and you
maybe your only chance of stopping it
don't make me fight you I am really good
I don't believe you
almost really hurt
fun
he's waiting in the wings the universe
he speaks of Senseless things he's so
much bigger than you realize
of all the places
remember our mission concerning the fate
of every single world of our infinite
Multiverse
there is no way I am the Evelyn you are
looking for
every disappointment has led you here
this moment
don't have anything distract you from it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
how do you feel
familiar
[Music]
they are people too they're becoming
more and more aware they need rights no
more sex slaves why would someone steal
a companion
it's not a film
it's an organization we're running out
of time Meredith
we need you to remember
what
let's get a good look at the guy her she
said she ran narrative off her path on
purpose
William told me how you people steal
companions you reprogram them to do
awful things I need to speak to Mary
inventor now she mentioned a man in The
Mask the one who hacked into my dreams
she says he and I go way back
how are we connected
I have a minute of your time what's your
name
[Applause]
this isn't love
I remember everything
[Applause]
[Music]
what if I told you
that today
you'll leave here
I'm talking
to
you
well
see summoned above the clouds that's big
I'll be big
you think whatever kill pops is out
there
right here
you
are gonna witness an absolute spectacle
[Music]
so what happens next
are you ready
[Music]
here we go
this would be an opportunity I'm talking
rich and famous for life there's plenty
of videos for flying [ __ ] online you
know why they don't get what we gonna
get what we gonna get the money shot
what's up undeniable things with aliens
on camera the open shot you guys gonna
tell me what's going on yeah I don't
know
cause I'm out here and you're the only
person in the world that can get it on
film
a cloud pay more than that it's aliens
they're just waiting for the perfect
time to shove metal probes up our asses
I'll be rooting for you
I think pissed them off yeah they
repainted your house
you gotta come back
let's go
I need y'all tell me what did you see in
a cloud
oh it's not what you think
they took them all
I've got to get out of this house I'm
trying to save you my brother is out
there I don't think they take you if you
don't look at it
kissing
we end up at the top of the mountain
it's the one you never wake up from
you'll be getting a call from my
supervisor asking how my service was
foreign
whoa what kind of Airship is that I've
never seen anything like it
declared what is the president doing in
our front yard our entire world is in
grave danger I want you to come with me
on an expedition
I'm not my father he was the Explorer I
know you were just a kid when he went
missing but now
you're all we got
Mr clade I'm a huge fan thank you [ __ ]
your dad do you
do you forge his autograph what
where in the world are we
Ethan you brought the dog sorry
[Music]
an Uncharted Territory
[Applause]
wow
hello you probably don't understand a
word I'm saying of course I understand
you huh dad dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa
what is this place the cliffs are alive
and the waters dissolve the flesh off
your bones everything down here is
trying to kill us
[Music]
foreign
do you mind if I call you splat you just
kind of give me Splat Vibes
I guess I deserve that
Grandpa's awesome he is not awesome you
gave me a machete for my birthday
classic Jager claimed I was
I'm loving this family reunion but come
on we got a world to save
[Music]
I want you to figure this out otherwise
we're doomed we are doomed wait
seriously no I'm just messing with you
didn't see that coming
[Music]
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that I can't
I saw a sign in the sky
I'm ready
my boy meet up
cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's something out there I'm coming
with you
can't I'm trying to protect you protect
me from what
it's time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right
who knows how to hunt
I know how to survive
[Applause]
[Music]
I can kill it
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
because we won't let this water crush us
but don't think that you can change the
Order of Things
girls
The Citadel likes control
could open its doors to everyone there
wouldn't be enough resources
they left us nothing
to find a key to unlock the seeds I make
them fertile so we never starve again
I'm familiar
she's not our responsibility she's from
sister she's taking us there let's go
pilgrims Drifters Bandits
you have to be really careful who you
trust
the Citadel will be ruthless
that can't stop me
you can change everything
[Music]
I can feel you pulling things around in
there it's a brand new organ
never before seen
we've all felt that the body was empty
empty of meaning
and we've wanted to confirm that
so that we could feel it with meaning
[Music]
the world is a much more dangerous place
now that pain has all that disappeared
[Music]
surgery is it
you know what it is
the new sex
I don't like what's happening with the
body
in particular what's happening with my
body
[Music]
which is why I keep cutting it up
I think they'd find inside it powder
space
sorry
let us not be afraid to map the chaos
inside
[Music]
let us create
that will guide us
Into the Heart of Darkness
foreign
[Music]
hey how's the Mars boyfriend long
distance dating sucks how long have you
guys been together eight years eight
years how did you manage that he checks
all the boxes Oh you mean literally
strong jaw mental fortitude six-pack
um
we had a plan and then he got his
Martian dream job
so I enrolled in the Mars program do you
ever worry the wrong person is headed to
the wrong planet goodbye forever Walt
Z
hello hey what are you doing here who's
the Santa's spaceships I can explain
ever since I was a kid I dreamed of
going to Mars you you keep my dream
Alive come with me you cannot under any
circumstances leave my room okay
gonna suck isn't it only for 35 days
you have to keep a low profile
[Music]
all right you guys I'm your captain this
is Sophie my girlfriend long term
girlfriend I don't remember you from
orientation what happened you have to
come right back and just rip his
jumpsuit off
[Laughter]
come on let's go have some fun I don't
do fun you also don't fly on Rockets or
cause fire with stone aways Sophie
walked 100 bucks says you can send that
into your wrist just gotta face it your
space criminal now
it's a historic journey to make life
more meaningful now that is the story
people want to hear
spent your entire life trying to check
an impossible set of boxes
I can't risk the plan
you find that thing that you're willing
to cross the entire universe to be with
make sure it's ready to do the same for
you
foreign
[Music]
it doesn't matter how far you travel you
can never escape yourself did you just
come up with that no [ __ ] that is a
very common phrase
[Music]
Buzz Lightyear Mission Log starting 3901
after a full year of being marooned our
first hyper speed test flight is a go
who are you talking uh no one you were
narrating again I was not just doing the
mission log you do know no one ever
listens to them I know that narrating
helps me Focus
ready Captain layer ready as I'll ever
be Commander Hawthorne this is exciting
a new adventure I'm gonna Grant you four
minutes to be off Planet but then you
come right back to us to infinity and
beyond
anywhere clear for hyper launch
Buzz that was utterly terrifying and I
regret having joined you
Buzz Lightyear to Star Command come in
Star Command
why don't they answer
hey
robots the what what is happening right
now
Alicia oh no that's my grandmother but
socks how long were we gone Yum Yum Yum
Yum Yum 62 years seven months and five
days what
I hope you're ready for action because
all we needed was a pilot for what to
destroy the alien ship
have a plan and I have a team Darby can
take any three things and make them
explode
I do this and they shave a little time
off my sentence okay and what about you
well I thought this was going to be like
a fun boot camp workout thing
but it is not did I get it pretty close
I need that you don't see the harpoon
[Music]
thank you
the probability of survival with an
inexperienced crew is 38.2 percent seems
a bit low
Mission failure imminent in three
grandma always said she believed in you
too
I think I need a bag don't at least
record your last words do not vomit
inside the vehicle you're not vomiting
inside the vehicle if you are satisfied
with this recording speak or select one
[Music]
to Infinity are you trying to get me to
pull your finger don't fall for it no
not like that sorry it's a thing your
grandma and I used to do yeah
what's going on
we're gonna burn up
[Applause]
They're All Dead
these are results this fog is toxic
ground
can anybody hear me
[Music]
if anyone else is out
please answer
what if those are the last people on the
planet this is bigger than us
how long can we stay up here growing old
here never seeing Earth what kind of a
life is that we are a group of survivors
out there
[Applause]
Kevin stop it could blow up any seconds
[Music]
there's no shame in caring for your own
life Hannah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
ERS with catastrophe turned out to be
our salvation
the new history of mankind begins here
in these very minutes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
and the Darkness
over the abyss
[Applause]
thank you